the virus lockdown hasn't stopped the
England star entertaining his fans and
keeping fit for football's return Ali
was at home with his girlfriend Ruby May
when Raiders broke in armed with knives
they punched him and stole the couple's
jewelry and watches Ali's teammate and
England captain Harry Kane offered his
support yeah not as normal I think it
was a bit short and a bit angry about
the situation but likely said thankfully
no one was no one was hurt no family was
hurt during the process which is amazing
really through the day police were in
and out in their search for clues Ali
and another man suffered minor facial
injuries officers spoke to two neighbors
in the road lined with millionaire homes
the player left later at the wheel of
the glitziest of his several cars behind
the dark glass he was wearing his
Tottenham Hotspur training gear well
enough for a few hours at the club's
coaching centre nearby
he told fans on Twitter thank you for
all the messages horrible experience but
we're all okay now
appreciate the support Ali may regret
this Instagram post he's wearing an
expensive watch and not the first time
he's shown it off well nobody asked to
be a victim of crime but sadly
high-profile young people like this
unfortunate footballer are very
regularly targeted by violent criminals
if you're going to wear very expensive
watches have nice smart cars and leave
them outside on display there are people
are going to target you especially if
you put it on Instagram two months ago
Ali's Spurs teammate Yan Vertonghen had
his home raided by burglars with knives
and machetes while he was playing abroad
and former England players Frank Lampard
and Ashley Cole were victims of similar
attacks last year the Arsenal star Mesut
özil
and a teammate survived unscathed after
an attempted carjacking when the robbers
broke in here Delhi Ali was playing pool
with his brother their partners and a
male friend were also in the house one
report said the Raiders managed to get
past a resident security guard as Ali
arrived back from training police were
appealing to anyone with information
about the robbery
Martin brunt Sky News North London